supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg has died at the age of 87
but according to several highly
reputable sources in the mainstream
media
the late justice has never felt better
and fully intends to finish out the
court's term
if you thought 2020 had reached peak
madness buckle up i'm michael knowles
this the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show biggest news
that could have possibly happened just
about
in the 2020 election cycle has happened
uh justice ruth bader ginsburg has died
you know the mainstream media have been
saying now for years and years after
this woman has battled all sorts of
cancers and she was obviously up there
in age they keep saying oh she's doing
great she's fine not a worry at all
but but of course they can't continue to
keep making that protestation and uh
uh ruth bader ginsburg has gone to her
eternal rest and we have gone to our
eternal
unrest in the madness that will follow
we will get into
all of the many lies that are being told
right now
about what what this means for the court
what this means for the election cycle
first
my favorite comment from thursday this
is from gs
on youtube um i don't think china
is who hollywood has sold its soul to
that's true
that's true it's not just china china is
a sort of stand-in
there's also a moral and a philosophical
dimension here as well
and you see that actually that same sort
of thing at play in the supreme court
rbg is gone and the democrats are
threatening civil war this from
beau williman uh he's some show business
blue check
he says quote we're shutting this
country down if trump and mcconnell
try to ram through an appointment before
the election well
jokes on you bo you already shut this
country down
you shut it down six months ago over the
china virus
and really just because orange man is
bad and you you guys
all thought that by shutting down the
country and driving everybody crazy and
crashing the economy you'd have a better
chance of winning the election so now
now that you want to do it over a court
vacancy
you can't because you've already done it
uh former cnn host and
noted cannibal rizza aslan tweets out if
they even try
to replace rbg we burn the entire
effing thing down once again mr astland
jokes on you you've already been burning
the country down for six months
listen to this madness if they try to
fill a court vacancy
if they try to do one of the basic
functions of government that the
constitution tells the president and
senate to do
they will burn the country down well of
course they're willing to burn the
country down
over anything they're willing to burn
the country down over
justified use of police force they're
willing to burn the country down
over the election of a republican
president they're willing to burn the
country down
over just about anything many others are
threatening violence that's a bad
reaction
to justice ginsburg's death how about a
decent reaction for that we turn
to president trump who is giving a rally
when the justice
passed away when the news broke and so
he was asked
he was sort of told of this news for the
first time by
a reporter everyone is a little nervous
you know sometimes president trump can
speak off the cuff and it get it's a
little
impolitic but i have to tell you he
handled this beautifully
she just died wow
i didn't know that i just you're telling
me now for the first time
she led an amazing life what else can
you say she was an amazing woman
whether you agreed or not she was an
amazing woman
who led an amazing life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect response from the president of
the united states the fact that you had
elton john playing in the background
after this rally
it just makes it all the more cinematic
hold me closer and these dare gives this
very empathetic early sympathetic
response
so that was great how should the rest of
us react i was actually
doing a radio interview when this news
broke so i didn't have any time to think
of it either
and i was asked breaking news the
justices died
uh what's your take first reaction is
we should pray for justice ginsburg's
soul we should pray that she gets to go
see her old buddy nino scalia again
don't forget
antonin scalia who we all love her his
best friend on the court
was ruth ginsburg and so we should pray
for her because now she's gone and
hopefully she gets to see her buddy
again
i don't think we need to sugarcoat this
i've seen some conservatives come out
and say oh wow we all need to be like
ginsburg
she was notorious she was so wonderful
she was so great you don't you don't
need to say that
she stood for very bad things on the
court and
we don't need to pretend that all of a
sudden now we agree with those things
she she certainly lasted a long time
and she she certainly had some
good opinions and and she had uh as a
matter of judicial opinions mostly bad
opinions
but uh but you know she's still a human
being and we should pray for her when
she dies
some people are saying this is a tragedy
that it's a tragedy that ginsburg has
died it's not a tragedy
when a woman dies at the age of 87
having accomplished everything in her
life that she's wanted to accomplish
that's not a trap it's a tragedy
when a little kid gets an illness and
dies
it's not a tragedy when someone lives
their natural life and has a life that
they're
happy about really the only tragedy that
ruth ginsburg endured is that the
democrats were so hell-bent
on killing babies that they wouldn't let
this poor woman retire
that's the tragedy this woman didn't get
two seconds of retirement
because the democrats were so intent on
keeping
one very bad court decision roe versus
wade
in play here it shows you how weak that
roe v wade decision is because
that's what all of this is about that's
what the whole
thing is about is roe versus wade
which in 1973 invented the fictional
constitutional right
to kill a baby in his mother's womb
and because there's obviously no
constitutional basis for that right
whatsoever
the courts have become hyper politicized
this isn't about any other issues
obamacare
redefining marriage even really intense
issues no those aren't threatened at all
by these courts
it's just roe versus wade when democrats
are threatening to burn down the country
right now rizza aslan and bo williman
and all these people
they're threatening to burn it down if
the right to kill a baby
in his mother's womb is ever even
remotely
threatened consider that's amazing
that's an amazing fact that shows you
that sometimes bad ideas drive people
mad or maybe spiritual things ride
people mad and it leads them to bad
ideas
so it's not tragic that ruth ginsburg
died but it is still sad and we should
still pray for her i'm seeing some other
people now come out and say
we who cares about ruth ginsburg no we
we should care
because in the words of john dunn any
man's death diminishes me
because i am a part of mankind right so
therefore never send for whom the bell
tolls the tools for me
should pray it's a nice thing to do and
we should move on now and look at the
political realities of this court
we've been told that ruth ginsburg's
dying wish
was that no conservative gets to replace
her i was her dying witch
well i'm i'd like to grant people's
dying wish but that's one i don't think
we can grant we'll get to that in one
second first
though got to thank our friends over at
rock auto
you know i never want to go to the car
part store mostly because i don't know
anything about car parts i don't know
very much about cars and these guys
always know they can scam me
luckily though i have rockauto.com which
is so much easier than walking into a
store
and rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
what happens when you walk into that
brick and mortar car part store they
don't have the car
part that you want they go online
usually to rock auto i would bet
then they charge you double for it don't
do it go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers
the thing about this website you know
that i don't know much about cars
the website is so easy to navigate even
i can do it and they're always fair you
don't have to look for the special
gimmick at this time in that time no
always reliably low prices these is a
family business you can count on them
amazing selection go to rockauto.com
right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck
head on over do it but most important of
all write nulls k-n-w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you you
know daily wires moving to the heartland
pretty soon
i'm gonna have to start learning how to
work on cars so that i can be a proper
true american man
guess where i'm gonna go first place
when i'm working on my cars
rockauto.com write in noel so they know
we sent you
according to many democrats i don't even
know if this is true poor a
poor rbg rather has been so
exploited particularly in her latter
years by the left that we don't even
really know if this is true or not but
we're told her dying wish
is that trump not replace her
aoc i don't know i guess she has some
inside knowledge here
delivers that final message the very
last
dying wish of rbg
was that her vacancy not be filled
until the new president takes office
in january that was her dying wish
tonight
mitch mcconnell publicly
the night that she the night of her
passing he couldn't wait
24 hours issued a statement
saying that he was going to
give trump a vote in violation of of her
dying wish
people can say how appalling people
could say this is horrible
etc but we know who this man is
we know who this man is this is a man
who does not care about a dying woman's
final wish
clearly hashtag me too i do not care
about this dying wish
i certainly i certainly do not care that
this justice who i'll take scalia at his
word
maybe she was a very nice lady but she
was hyper hyper partisan
and i don't care that she allegedly
said this very partisan thing at the end
of her life
i'll tell you what i heard here's just
what i heard and who knows if it's true
i just heard it
that anton scalia's dying wish was that
roe versus wade be overturned
so are you really going to deny the man
his dying wish
look it's his dying wish he said it it's
in the constitution it's
right there in one of the penumbras and
the emanations the dying wish doctrine
that if someone on the court wants
anything at the end of their life you
have to give it to them
so look that's i'm pretty sure also
scalia said
that the treasury should give me at
least
four to ten million dollars i remember i
heard it from
somebody said it and you know it's in
the penumbras so anyway give me give me
my money please
not how our constitution works huh there
is lots of confusion about how our
constitution works
even some republicans like mitt romney
or lisa murkowski or susan collins
now want to honor rbg's wish and not
confirm a judge
i will take you through in a whirlwind i
will take you through
all of the ridiculous and dishonest
arguments going on right now about
whether or not we should fill
the court seat just to give you the
top-line view should we fill the vacancy
yes of course we should fill the vacancy
this is going to be
a very bad faith fight with a lot of bad
faith arguments including from some
people on the right
in the midst of all this political
posturing everybody is missing the point
so
the first argument this is the first
point that the democrats are making bill
clinton just made it the other day
it's that mitch mcconnell would be a
hypocrite
to fill this seat in an election year
after he refused to fill
antonin scalia's seat with obama's
appointee
during 2016. we're really close to the
election
and uh let's remember the example
abraham lincoln said and let's remember
the commitments and the comments mitch
mcconnell made it
i think it would be good for senator
mcconnell to make him feel better when
he gets up in the morning
if he if he proved that he wasn't being
a hypocrite at the time
and he just stuck with his position and
i think
all the other republicans could should
be asked to do the same
but you know you can't
keep a democracy if there's one set of
rules for one group and another set for
everybody else
you heard it from old bubba himself who
definitely would never play by a
different set of rules than his
political opponents right no not bill
clinton
you kidding me the clintons you they
could never be hypocritical but that's
the
that's the point they're making i don't
even care i'm not even going to get into
the clintons today
the point they're making is mitch
mcconnell's hypocrite because he
wouldn't he wouldn't fill the seat in
2016 but he wants to fill it now
well okay what did mitch mcconnell say
what precisely is the mcconnell rule
from
2016. it's campaign season
we're right in the middle of it been
more than 80 years
since a supreme court vacancy arose and
was filled
in a presidential election year
[Music]
there will not be hearings or votes the
next president whoever that may be
is going to be the person who chooses
the next supreme court justice
boom he's a hypocrite he's a hypocrite
right he has to be because he wouldn't
fill the seat in 2016
but he wants to fill it now that's the
mcconnell rule except
is that the eternal mcconnell rule that
you can't ever fill a court seat during
an election year or was that a rule
specific
to that time well it gets a little more
complicated because at the time
in 2016 democrats were lambasting
mcconnell
for not filling that seat except do you
know where mcconnell got that rule from
he got that rule from joe biden the
current democratic nominee we'll get to
that one second first though got to
thank our friends
over at lifelock you know it's very
very important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft
can affect your lives you don't want to
get hacked
you don't want to feel dumb because you
didn't take the precautions you could at
the time
but i know every we think that no one's
coming after our data
we think nobody's coming after us on the
internet
they are every day we put our
information at risk on the internet
especially now because everybody's
working from home there's a home
schooling
the cyber criminals have reacted to that
good thing
there's lifelock lifelock detects a wide
range of identity threats
like your social security number for
sale on the dark web if they
detect that your information is there
they will send you an
alert what i'm hoping for you is that
you go
you get life lock you you totally set it
up you get it going
and then you forget about it and you
never even have to thank me
for saving your identity from being
stolen
because that's the thing you when you're
when you're protected you're protected
right
now you will be kicking yourself if you
go and leave all of your identity out
there on the internet
and then you have to deal with some
problems i promise you just go take care
of it now an
ounce of prevention is worth a pound of
cure now no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can find out
if your information is on the dark web
get your free dark web scan at
lifelock.com
knowles pick the plan that's right for
you save up to 25
off your first year with promo code
knowles freescan at lifelock.com
knowles 25 off of promo code noles canon
wles
so mcconnell's a hypocrite right because
he wouldn't fill the seat then
and he wants to fill the seat now but he
was
evil then remember they were all upset
that he wouldn't fill the seat then so
then by their logic shouldn't
shouldn't they be excited that we're
going to fill the seat now well i don't
know because the mcconnell rule
actually comes from the biden rule which
was given back in 1992
where joe biden said absolutely not
under no circumstances
should the president put forth the
nominee now why did he say that because
there was a republican president
who would be picking the nominee it is
my view
that if a supreme court justice resigns
tomorrow or within the next several
weeks
or resigns at the end of the summer
president bush should consider following
the practice of a majority of his
predecessors
and not and not name a nominee
until after the november election is
completed
the senate too mr president must
consider
how it would respond to a supreme court
vacancy
that would occur in the full throes of
an election year
it is my view that if the president goes
the way
of presidents fillmore and johnson and
presses an election year nomination
the senate judiciary committee should
seriously consider
not scheduling confirmation hearings on
the nomination
until ever until after the political
campaign season is over okay now this is
getting really complicated because it
turns out that that mcconnell rule
in 2016 that the democrats were so upset
about was actually invented by joe biden
who's the guy that they just picked to
be their nominee for president
this year so to put it into perspective
you've got
on the side of do not appoint a
judge nominee in an election year you've
got
biden in 92 and mcconnell in 2016 and
then on the side of appoint
a judge in an election year you've got
mcconnell in 2020 but it gets even more
complicated than that because it turns
out that joe biden
after 2016 joe biden in
uh 2020 is for confirming
a judge in an election year here is here
is joe i guess not joe biden in 2020
because joe biden's changed his tune
again
but this is now uh joe biden
not in 1992 after the merrick garland
fiasco
saying yes they should have confirmed a
judge
i made it absolutely clear that i would
go forward with the confirmation
progress
process as chairman even a few months
before a presidential election
if the nominee were chosen with the
advice and not merely the consent
of the senate just as the constitution
requires
just as the constitution requires
president can put forth a nominee and
that's great we'll have him so
i'm i'm sorry to keep you spinning in a
whirlwind
of changing opinions biden 92
don't put a judge on the court biden
2016-2017 yes put a judge on the court
mcconnell back in 2016
do not put the judge on the court
mcconnell 2020 put the judge on the
court
democrats now saying absolutely you
cannot put the judge
on the court in an election year
democrats in 2016
all of the top democrats in 2016 you
must put the judge on the court
the american people deserve a fully
staffed court of nine
the president nominates and then the
senate advises
and consents or not but they go forward
with the process
what we're seeing here and hope this is
temporary is a disrespect for the
constitution the constitution
is 100 percent clear the president
of the united states has the right to
nominate
someone to be a justice of the supreme
court senate's function
is to hold hearings and to vote the
blockade on filling a naturally
occurring vacancy
in my view is harmful to the
independence of the article 3 branch
you cannot keep a seat on the supreme
court
which represents all of us you cannot
keep it vacant
against the constitution do pretty much
everything they can
to avoid acknowledging the legitimacy of
our democratically
elected president the american people
expend the president's nominee
to be given a fair hearing and a timely
vote in the senate
every day that goes by without a ninth
justice is another day the americans
people's business
is not getting done oh i love that
symphony i love that symphony because
you have every top
democrat in 2016 making the opposite
argument
than they are making right now and sure
maybe mcconnell's doing that a little
bit too and joe biden's done it multiple
times totally swinging from side to side
does this mean that they're hypocrites
no it means they're very funny
means they're very funny people and it
means that some of them are unserious
people but it does not
actually mean that they're hypocrites at
least mcconnell's not a hypocrite the
people trying to make the eternal
arguments universal here's the rule for
all time
there's a little hypocrisy there but the
people making the argument
no in this election year we shouldn't
put up a judge in this election year
maybe we should put up a judge
that's not hypocritical that is about
power
this is a very simple issue the
constitution says that the president
has the right to put forward a judge
nominee
the senate has the right to advise and
consent to or reject that nominee
and then when they consent to it the
judge is put on the court
very simple there is nothing complicated
about that there's nothing controversial
about that
anybody who is trying to tell you that
this is complicated or controversial is
deceiving you or deceiving themselves so
what changes
what changes is power right now
we have a republican president and a
republican senate so we can
probably maybe except the republicans
are so useless but we can maybe get a
judge nominee through
good 2016 you had a democrat president
a republican senate they weren't going
to get a judge nominee through okay cool
great that's power that's how it works
there's nothing hypocritical
about elected politicians using the
power
entrusted in them by the people
according to the constitution nothing
hypocritical
at all all about power what there is a
kind of funny
coincidence here which is that this
brutal confirmation process
for the supreme court was a very modern
thing and it is
in part joe biden's legacy it's ted
kennedy and joe biden
joe biden with clarence thomas ted
kennedy with judge borg and it's all
about roe v wade it's all about abortion
this started
when conservative judge bork was being
put up for the court in the 1980s
and kennedy used in particular the issue
of abortion to demagogue the issue
in robert forks america there is no room
at the end for blacks
and no place in the constitution for
women and in our america there should be
no seat on the supreme court
for robert bork mr bork has been equally
extreme
in his opposition to the right to
privacy
in an article in 1971 he said in effect
that a husband
and wife have no greater right to
privacy
under the constitution than a smokestack
has
to pollute the air this was
unprecedented in supreme court
nominations where you have this
this murderer ted kennedy that's not
it's unbelievable
unbelievable right that ted kennedy this
womanizing drunk
killer of his mistress comes out and
calls
judge borg an absolutely upright man
some sort of a sexist
that's a beautiful thing and that it's
so hilarious it's so outrageous
that you know it strains credulity he
calls him a racist too of course you can
call him all these things
and he shoots down the nomination of a
qualified guy
these judges used to sail through they'd
be confirmed unanimously
but because in particular the issue of
roe v wade
was decided on such preposterous
constitutional grounds
they now need to have their own hyper
partisans
in the mold of breyer or ginsburg or any
of these other people
to be put on the bench to protect that
fictional right
and they do it and they do it and
instead of work we got kennedy and
kennedy became a liberal
and threw our jurisprudence into
absolute madness
biden tried to do this to clarence
thomas
when when he was nominated by george h.w
bush he tried to do it to thomas
fortunately thomas was a bit quicker on
his feet he was a little more clever
totally shut it down
committee will please come to order
judge a tough day and tough night for
you i know
let me uh ask do you have anything you'd
like to say
before we begin this is a circus it's a
national disgrace
and from my standpoint as a black
american as far as i'm concerned
it is a high-tech lynching for uppity
blacks
who in any way deign to think for
themselves
to do for themselves to have different
ideas
and it is a message that unless you cow
town
to an old order this is what will happen
to you
you will be lynched destroyed
caricatured
by a committee of the u.s u.s senate
rather than hung from a tree you know
you can't see it in that
particular clip you can see it in others
the minute
that clarence thomas brings this point
up
the the high-tech lynching point joe
biden who's cheering the committee his
head goes right down he goes oh
shoot we're the only ones who are
supposed to play the race card the race
card's for democrats republicans can't
play the race card ah
darn i guess we're gonna have to let
this guy through huh
it's a it's a beautiful you should watch
the entire statement
that uh clarence thomas gives but that
point there then he goes this is a
high-tech lynching for uppity blacks who
in any way deign to think for themselves
and they'll be lynched by a committee of
the senate rather than hung from a tree
guess what happened then they confirmed
it didn't work this was the moment that
andrew breitbart says made him
conservative it radicalized him
because he saw that even
even more than the borking what they
would do to any conservative
who threatened the liberal regime of
completely imaginary constitutional
rights that was subverting our
constitution
so democrats did this joe biden in
particular did this they've been doing
it for over 40 years
republicans have never done this we've
never done this to
any democratic judicial nominee part of
me is hoping
that trump will nominate merrick garland
just so
that the democrats will be forced to
call him a rapist because that's the new
thing now if you if you're put up for
the supreme court you're called a rapist
that's the rule they'll do it too
they'll probably do it to amy barrett
amy barrett is now
considered to be the leading contender
to replace ruth ginsburg
well we'll get into that in one second
we'll get into who and how we should
fill
this vacancy lots of lots of takes from
the left that are actually the opposite
of of the reality it tells us a lot more
about the left-wing view of women and
the judiciary
than the conservative view which we'll
get into in one second but first if you
watch this podcast on youtube you got to
know that on
september 28th it will be moving from
the daily wire channel
to be available exclusively on my
youtube channel the michael knowles show
you can get the link in the description
below some people have written and asked
if i am leaving the daily wire
i saw actually saw some people in orange
county yesterday came up to me said
you're leaving the daily
wire i'm not leaving the daily wire ben
shapiro is not so lucky
uh we're all staying on the daily wire
but we're moving the show
the live shows every single day to the
show youtube channels this has more to
do with big tech
than it does anything with the daily
wire so subscribe over to the youtube
channel michael knowles show
ring the bell make sure you never miss
out on a new video head on over to
dailywire.com
we will be right back with a whole lot
more
should we fill the vacancy absolutely
should we
get rid of the filibuster to do it
absolutely one issue now is that we have
this rule called the filibuster which
means you need 60 votes to get anything
done not a simple majority
should we get rid of it yes the
filibuster is not part of the
constitution
it's only been theoretically possible
since 1806 it's only been used since the
mid
18th 19th century it's only really been
used in earnest since the 1970s
and harry reid and the democrats got rid
of it for most appointees executive and
judicial
back in 2013 and mcconnell warned him he
said don't do this you're going to
regret it
well now is the time for it to be
regretted by the democrats they're
already promising to get rid of it if
they come to power we won't get any
cookies or brownie points for
maintaining this tradition and
and tying one arm behind our back so
yeah absolutely 100
fill the post question is who should it
be the leading contender right now
amy coney barrett
three words that strike fear under the
heart of the liberals
who is amy barrett she's an appeals
court judge she's a mother of
seven five biological children two
adopted children from haiti
she's a law professor obviously
qualified we don't know much about
her judicial philosophy actually we know
she clerked for scalia
but you know she's young she's been on
the bench not too long
still the left hates her guts why two
big reasons first one they hate her
primarily because
she's catholic here is senator democrat
dianne feinstein
lambasting her because the catholic
dogma lives loudly within her
when you read your speeches
the conclusion one draws
is that the dogma lives
loudly within you and
that's of concern when you come to big
issues
that large numbers of people have fought
for
for years in this country it's a big
concern
because catholics aren't allowed on the
supreme court because
our constitution establishes a religious
test for president
and you need to belong to the religion
of secular liberalism you can't possibly
be a christian
that would be un-american that's the
argument she's making
luckily dianne feinstein is far too
ignorant to know that that's the
argument that she's making but it's a
deeply anti-american argument the things
she is saying
right there violate the constitution
even
asking those questions is a violation of
the constitution
dick durbin another leading democrat a
little bit quicker on his feet than
dianne feinstein
falls into precisely the same trap you
use a term in that article
or you both use a terminate article i've
never seen before you refer to orthodox
catholics
what's an orthodox catholic um
as i recall that term we said something
like for lack of a better term
we're using the term orthodox catholic
and there was a long footnote saying
you know that that was an imperfect term
it could
you know refer to orthodox judaism you
know greek orthodox and so we kind of
cast about but what that term was
designed to capture
because we were talking about
conscientious objection was a judge
who accepted the church's teaching that
the death penalty
would be impermissible in that case do
you consider yourself an orthodox
catholic
i am a catholic senator durbin i i don't
well orthodox catholic we kind of
as i said in that article we just kind
of use that as a proxy
it is not to my knowledge you know a
term currently in use but if you're
asking whether i take my faith seriously
and i'm a
faithful catholic i am although i would
stress that my
personal church affiliation or my
religious belief would not bear on the
discharge of my duties as a judge
she gave a very long judicial sort of
judicious
answer here but a simpler answer
is what do you mean you've never heard
of orthodox
catholic dick durbin is not a stupid man
he says i've never heard that orthodox
catholic well let me spell it out for
you senator durbin
orthodox meaning you actually believe
the things that you say that you believe
catholic meaning you're a catholic
you're you're part of the catholic
church
you could be a heterodox catholic
meaning you consider yourself a catholic
but you don't believe the things
that the catholic church believes you
could be a heretic a heretical catholic
you could openly preach things against
what the catholic church teaches even
though you consider yourself a catholic
or you can be an orthodox catholic and
actually believe the things the catholic
church teaches
and that's the issue here because when
democrats use the term catholic
they say i'm a devout catholic my
catholic faith is important to me
what they really mean is i
have christmas dinner i maybe go to mass
sometimes if i want to
that's what they mean joe biden's a
devout catholic he thinks that
taxpayers should should pay to kill
babies in the womb up until the moment
of birth
but he's a which which catholics are not
permitted to believe
but you know he's a devout catholic some
democrats say yeah
i support socialism but i'm a devout
catholic you're not allowed to be a
socialist
if you're a catholic so what they mean
by devout catholic is they think that
religion is this kind of little ornament
and it's this sweet little thing that
maybe you do in the privacy of your own
home
because you're afraid of the dark and
it's a little superstition like knocking
on wood
or or any other superstition but you
don't take it seriously you don't think
it means anything
you certainly don't believe all that
crazy
stuff that those churches say and the
democrats are shocked to find
a woman who's intelligent who is
articulate
who is accomplished who actually thinks
it's true and now
there are a lot of catholics and and
christians and
people who think this way but the
democrats don't meet them they're always
shocked
you know you couldn't possibly believe
that stuff so that's the first reason
they hate her second reason they hate
her
is because she disproves all their
stupid theories about how women are
supposed to be
on paper she is everything
a woman should be or could be the left
always says
women can have it all right and usually
what that means is
that women should go and delay getting
married and delay having children
and just work for the widget factory and
you know
they should go cut their hair and they
should go only vote for democrats and
they should have lots of abortions
and they should uh i don't know what are
all the things i'm trying to
mix the high and the low you know you
get like stupid like
really like ugly haircuts like do you
remember that thing that the democrats
were doing years ago the feminist women
were
it's like it was very unpleasant and
the very important things like they
should
engage in abortion or they should form
families in a certain way this or that
or this or that
that's what the democrats say you can
you can have it all
that's the promise that you can have a
career
have a family have kids
do all these things you want usually it
doesn't work out that way
so you have to fall into one one camper
the other but for amy barrett it did
work out that way
she had five biological kids she then
adopted two children from haiti they'll
find some way to call her a racist i'm
sure
she found a way to have this incredibly
successful legal career
and yet they still hate her how do they
hate her
she did what most of them never could do
she had it all well
it's because she doesn't think the way
that they do
new york times runs a piece two
conservatives barrett has perfect
combination of attributes for the
supreme court
maybe that's true for conservatives but
actually it's more true for liberals
the headline should read to liberals
barrett has the perfect combination of
attributes for the supreme court
she's a woman and they think that a
woman needs to replace ruth ginsburg
she's has it all she has had this great
career but she hasn't had to sacrifice
in her personal life
or not at least that we can see she
checks all of these kind of boxes right
i don't care that amy barrett's a woman
i don't think a woman needs to replace
rbg on the supreme court i don't think a
woman needs to have it all you know
needs to have this very intense career
and have a total family life i don't i
don't think you
have to do that but they do
and she did it but she doesn't think the
way that they think
so now all of a sudden
they hate her they're going to try to
kick her out uh we absolutely should
push her through
if for no other reason than to trigger
the libs it'll be very very funny
also the reason we need to push her
through i think we should all get on
board
if it's her it might be there a couple
other people are being talked about
she's the leading contender right now
but the reason we need to push through
this nominee if the nominee is in any
way acceptable to conservatives
is because we're in a bare-knuckle
moment of politics right now we're not
in a nice deliberative moment of
politics where
all these judicial nominees get
unanimously confirmed
that's gone and the democrats ruined
that and so we've got to play
we've got to participate in the politics
that we actually have
this is bare knuckle stuff right now
there's a poll out that just
just 22 percent of americans believe
that this year's presidential election
will be free and fair
this according to yahoo news and yougov
22
little over one in five americans think
the election will be free and fair
half of trump supporters say the
election will not be free and fair
more than a third of biden supporters
agree it will not be free and fair
it's about 46 percent
say that the election will not be free
and fair which is more than twice the
percentage of americans
who say that it will be
you're now at a place where a small
number of americans have faith
in that institution of our free
elections
so now you've got to exercise power in a
way that's a little less subtle
than perhaps you would in the fast in
the past part of the reason
why i think americans don't believe all
this stuff
is that everything seems fake right now
the lockdown has really contributed to
this
there are a lot of reasons why we don't
have faith in our institutions anymore
but
one reason i haven't heard people talk
about it and it does come from kovid
is the degree to which now everything is
virtual everything is digital
the emmys were last night i know that
nobody watched it
but what was so weird about the emmys is
that the emmys didn't really take place
it looked like they took place but they
didn't
what happened was the emmys
used jimmy kimmel on a green screen to
host the thing
and then cut to footage from past years
to make it seem like people were
laughing
at the jokes he made the jokes weren't
that funny the way you knew there was a
laugh rag is that people were laughing
at it sounded like people were laughing
at them so you know that couldn't
possibly have happened
the whole thing was just a weird
virtual award show take a listen
well hello and welcome to the pandemies
wow it's great to finally see people
again
thank you for risking everything to be
here thank
me for risking everything to be here you
know what they say
you can't have a virus without a host
the big question that i guess we should
answer is why would you
have an award show in the middle of a
pandemic
no seriously i'm asking why are we
having an award show in the middle of a
pandemic
and what the hell am i doing here this
is the year
they decide they have to have a host a
lot of growners
in jimmy's monologue was not very good
and then you're looking at the crate you
say wait none of them are wearing masks
right they're all together wait they're
laughing at those dumb jokes oh cause
it's all fake
the whole thing is fake and so this is a
problem it's not jimmy kimmel's fault
necessarily or the emmys this is one
that has grown over time
and it's not even our politicians fault
it's a actually a technological problem
i i was
reading an article about deep fakes the
other day deep fake photos and videos
where it looks like someone is saying
something that they aren't actually
saying
and part of me actually welcomes this
into politics
because now we live in such a gotcha
moment of politics that i think it would
be
it would actually maybe help our
politics if we can't trust
video as much video footage you know and
just say like i don't know maybe that's
real maybe that's not real
we'd have to start actually listening to
the arguments that our politicians are
making and looking at their actual
records rather than just these kind of
silly
gotcha moments but one effect of this
technology is
we don't trust reality anymore we don't
we don't
trust even things that we see with our
own eyes because we know that they can
be manipulated like the emmys or even
like our politicians because it's not
just the emmys that was glitching out
it's nancy pelosi nancy pelosi was
giving an interview on abc news
and halfway through the interview it
seems like her brain just melted and she
didn't know what this and she kind of
glitched out for a second
then they got the wires working again
and she continued
10 states as i said on friday i started
their early
voting the day that we lost ruth bader
ginsburg but to be clear you're not
taking any arrows out of your quiver
you're not ruling anything out
good morning sunday morning
the we have a responsibility
we take an oath to protect and defend
the constitution
of the united states you're going to
look at george stephanopoulos doing the
interview he's obviously a
a cl a clinton spokesman he's a democrat
flack
and even he's looking at he's like what
did i just witness
what happened to you huh
she just kind of totally glitches out
for about 10 seconds in there and then
gets back into it so we think okay i
can't trust what i see on video
i can't trust that these politicians are
at all with it they're completely
it's like they're they're not even alive
it's like they're just we're relying on
these people who have been in public
life now for 750 years
who seem to have a very tenuous grasp on
reality
so we can't trust them to make
persuasive arguments
more and more this is just a
bare-knuckle brawl for interests and
then you have the democratic nominee
for president who probably has the least
solid grasp on reality
just gave a speech about the coronavirus
in which he said that two-thirds of the
country was about to die
it's estimated that 200 million people
have died probably by the time i
finished this
talk but the complication of
cover 19 like lung scarring and heart
damage
could become the next deniable
pre-existing condition
for over 6 million
americans 200 millions are going to die
before joe biden finishes speaking
this is two-thirds of the country i've
got a 67 chance of dying goodbye cruel
world
goodbye i thought that i had a 99.7
chance of survival
even if i got the virus but turns out
just a regular joe on the street
has a two-thirds chance of dying of
course that is not true joe biden was
off by several numbers
mathematics critical thought economics
never has been
the democrats strong suit obviously he's
not with it either
so you look around and you just say gosh
nobody
is he is even capable of making
arguments right now
that could allow us to use reason and
use prudence to govern ourselves as our
constitution
was intended and there's a deeper
problem too
that goes to trevor noah a lot of
problems go to trevor noah he's the
guy who took over the daily show after
jon stewart and then everybody stopped
watching it
trevor noah said something on his show a
few weeks ago
and all this rbg
court talk has brought it back to me
which is trevor noah was talking about
the wildfires and
how the wildfires in the west were
started by a gender reveal party
and he made a joke about the gender
reveal party but what was so weird about
it was
the the basis of the joke was not
common sense usually usually what would
happen is you're
making a joke and the joke is something
bizarre and
fantastical that's what the setup is and
then the punch line brings you back to
common sense
but with trevor noah's joke the punch
line was
that gender is socially constructed and
we won't know somebody's gender until
they're 18 or so
the the premise of the joke the setup
was actually the common sense
and the punch line was bizarro world it
was an
inversion of a normal joke take a listen
guys this has to stop
right or at least if you insist on a
gender reveal you should do something
that
helps the situation the water's pink
it's a girl
and aside from all the damage it can
cause celebrating a baby's genitalia is
starting to feel very outdated
like given everything we're learning
about gender gender reveal parties
should only happen when the child is old
enough to know their actual gender
and to pitch in some cash for the fire
damage
so he gets that little like little jokey
bit
in at the very end which is yeah and
they've got to be able to pitch in cash
too
but he's dead serious when he says we
should hold off on gender reveals
until the kid is old enough to choose
his own gender
so you're now flipping a joke but not to
him because to him that's common sense
to a lot of people in the country maybe
not a lot maybe not half the country but
let's say a third or so
of these hardened left wingers seriously
believe
that you can't tell if a baby is a boy
or a girl at birth that you have to wait
until
they decide whether they're boys or
girls and maybe they're boys and they
become girls or vice versa
and what that shows you is the country
is more divided than we have ever been
more divided than we were at the time of
slavery
more divided than we were at the time of
the civil war the issue of slavery
was practically a much tougher issue
than the issue of gender or whatever
right because you're actually talking
about
all of these americans held in bondage
but the division over slavery was it was
a division over a group of people
it wasn't it was a division basically
over someone is a man or not a man
but it wasn't a division over
essentially what a man
is or is not the
the issue of of the civil war the issue
of
whether or not a certain group of people
qualifies
into humanity is a specific problem
because some people didn't recognize
humanity in a whole swath of the earth's
population
but now what we're talking about is
people don't recognize humanity at all
they don't recognize human nature at all
that's a much deeper divide so i don't
see any way to bridge that
now if you if you've got a huge number
of political activists saying they're
going to burn the country down if you in
any way threaten their right to kill a
baby in the womb
that's not recognizing human nature
that's not that's
it's not recognizing humanity at all
if you've got people in this country who
don't believe that there's such a thing
as sex so fundamental to our human
nature
how do you bridge that how do you have a
self-governing republic how do you make
persuasive arguments
when you preclude the possibility of
logical argument
then you just have a bare-knuckle brawl
and that's what we've been seeing for
the past six months in this country
something tells me it's only going to
get crazier at least
through election day probably afterward
as well on that happy note
that's our show i'm michael nolan's
michael noel shaw i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses
are life family faith
those are fundamental and that's what
this show is about i hope you'll
give it a listen